I don't have a lot of experience with  bubble blowing this sounds so sandy  wouldn't say that I'm very competitive  so if this is like a competition between  me and the other pink ladies and the  boys I'm gonna win it I'm really nervous  about about LeBlanc situation are there  any rules if a hole starts coming can I  like put it what's the technique I think  the last time I did it I was probably  like 10 so I don't know I'm from the  south I have a good southern blowing  technique you have to make sure you get  it to the point where the sugar isn't at  the top I need to find my inner bubble  ace you got you it for a long time I'm  not quite ready to do it yet  I'm competitive I play to win  sorry don't apologize Jordan  nope  Oh what what I gotta go family like this  after all I just did I got embarrassed  my mom skill hmm  whoa what is going on  I don't know what julienne secret is I  think she lucked out I think she gets  the jackpot and everything she's  beautiful she's talented